[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by kat graham aka
tamira and collide which is in theaters
now and on demand friday how you doing
today cat i'm good i'm good thanks for
having me on your show
oh thanks for coming on i'm excited to
talk to you i absolutely love this film
and i was amazed how suspenseful it is
and a lot of that's tribute to your
great performance in it now what's
interesting is people are going to see
your characters on a blind date with
this character of hunter
how long did it take to film just this
movie in general being in most of the
time in one setting in this movie
we were able to save a lot of time just
shooting in one location so i actually
only shot for about a week
um i know that they had they had been
filming before i'd even got got there
and they kept filming after me um i know
that jim definitely was shooting
more than i was but i was i was it was
you i thought initially when i got the
script i'm like oh
that seems pretty easy just do the scene
in a chair
it was the hardest
scenes i might have ever done as an
actor
okay that's amazing to say that i was
sitting in a chair the whole time so
that says a lot about what the kind of
film this was
yeah that's that's what i was gonna ask
you next too is like how challenging it
is it's such an emotional performance
you do but you have to stay seated
because of the situation the film is in
so
i mean why was it more challenging to
you what was it like did you always feel
an urge to want to get up like how did
you reserve a lot of energy
there was so there was so much to it um
it was it was just one of those things
where every single
line and beat and look and
moment was so carefully crafted in the
script we didn't want to miss anything
um
and
i never had to i mean i
it's hard to say i never had to
concentrate like that but just the
it's just these are big scenes um and
they are not
easily worded and they all have to make
sense it's just it was a very intense
film to do
yeah well you make it look easy which is
great and
in a film too you mentioned the script
where you know not spoiling but the
stories in a sense in some way or
another are connected as an actress do
you read the whole script or is it only
necessary for you really to read your
scenes no no no
i have to read a whole script um i have
to make sure it makes sense with
everything else and the thorough line of
the film and what the film is trying to
to convey and um
and what the colliding actually is right
between all of these characters that are
in this one place and this one night and
how that comes together and
uh no you have to read everything
for sure yeah no i like that and
it's interesting too because as we see
in the trailer there's a ticking time
bomb under hunter's chair so it makes
for his incredible suspense film are
there any thrillers though like this
that
you love that kind of maybe spoke to you
that were similar to this film yeah i
loved crash
which was worse one of my um
go-to films that i looked at once i
um started putting energy on this film
uh there's a lot of really cool
suspense
uh uh films um
um out of time is really good
um
training day
you know i was looking at any like high
stakes
films and there's so many great actors
in them so i was trying to find you know
the different different inspirations
that that would help me kind of
understand what i was getting myself
no yeah and it's cool to see you in this
because it's such a popular genre so
it's exciting to see kat graham kind of
take a swing at it and just everything
you've done your career is so impressive
from starring in a hit show of vampire
diaries and now you're in two netflix
films coming out this year and you're on
a world tour for your music so
what has been your secret for success
and staying there
daytime naps
a lot of hydration hell yeah
and um an organizer
i love it
um and then my last question yeah
and what is the ultimate next goal
venture for you because you already do
so much but like do you still have like
a list of things you're still trying to
hit
um
you know no that sounds weird i don't
feel like i've reached any peak in my
career by any means but i will say that
i'm learning how to kind of
um
let go and allow life to happen a bit
more it's kind of a wink to um
my film love in the villa that was a
lesson that i learned from that film is
to be able to to let go i obviously have
the things that i i work on
personally like my work with the refugee
agency and my wellness company so in
terms of trying to bring something
positive and
of service to the world that's always a
priority but i think in terms of my
acting maybe producing more
just just trying to kind of take a step
back and see where the world is at and
see what i'm am i using my skill set to
make it a better place to bring more
awareness to to conversations things
like that
i love that and you definitely do that
and i think everyone's excited to see
what you do next but we can all just
rejoice that you're in collide in
theaters now and it's on demand friday
everyone check out cat just be brilliant
in this cat thank you so much for
joining me today steve thank you and i
hope to talk to you again in the future
for watching